what is up reject nation my name is John
Humphrey and with me is the Kyle ermine
Kyle I Lerman the Kyle ermine that's why
that happened yes because your name is
kind of tongue twist it is Kyle I Lerman
from fancier fan Theory channel get on
there check them out Kyle are you
initiated in the ways of the wrecker
wrecker uh pseudo pseudo okay I do seen
some of those yeah so other doing these
new blogs they just moved into a mansion
of sorts and they're making a whole
bunch more videos lately and this one
called roommate fistfight okay get ready
there's probably going to be a lot of
crazy camera angle than a lot of
screaming in a lot of blood my ear here
we go actually we have yes and I do if
you like chomps die dude Oh is there a
child a she an angel
let's go fine do you like chomp
I'm never going to try to formulate a
talking about give me the actual okay
okay I've had a chomp before one shot
one picture as well this time it
features Mountain Dew
oh here we go
Michael Mary
[Music]
whoa Oh mr. mommy Joe come on hey well
tonight you're warned jobs in the
[ __ ] dishes bro come on man this is
no my husband's not able to do dishes
hey watch the thing thing oh I copied
[ __ ] telephone [ __ ] you guys in the
comments do you like most recent video
wasn't this watch it you guys just a
fight why is it no [ __ ] fight when
you start the [ __ ] out so much because
you didn't book what [ __ ] videos
would be [ __ ] what everyone I'm still
you had the kind of brewskis man there's
no violence
you don't need a fight but you can at
least include a little punch here there
you guys don't even do that
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
Oh
Oh Ronnie and lowdown this time you slow
in igloo the harder you do oh did you
see the animal video no oh it's pretty
special
oh my god oh man yeah see the thing is
every time we react to one of these
videos we inevitably end up speculating
as to what it would be like to actually
just spend some time with these guys I
am fascinated by the idea of what it
really is like to live in that house
because half of me thinks that it is
definitely like this most of the time
and the other half of me thinks that it
is nothing like this at all as the truth
is probably somewhere yeah but either
way it's impressive is either they're
really impressive because it's all for
show or these guys are legit and you've
got to give them respect for that boss
okay the thing that's cool about these
vlogs to me and I like that even in this
video like they they acknowledge the
other like have you seen the comment on
your last video people like what is this
vlog [ __ ] these are super affected to me
because like I fight you know it's that
blurry line between reality and fiction
where it's like are they just destroying
things in their house or is this very
carefully mapped because it looks like
they're just destroying their home so
cool I mean it seems like they're very
used to that and they probably wouldn't
have any trouble fixing anything and and
Ron has been a while since I've seen Ron
in one of these and that's probably the
most exciting like post-credits ting
I've seen in a long time you know have
you seen any other on my thumb I have
not but now I need to imagine the
Devil's Rejects but like you know a
little more Troma and you know with
McDonald's and yes these guys have like
a crazy knack for fighter like I think
they're working on a movie right now and
I cannot wait to see what that looks
like I feel like these dudes are going
to make whatever the next hardcore Henry
at some kind of movie that is just so
intense and so over the top over the top
over the top hop hop hopping off the
wall and I'm glad that they're posting
more honestly like I love this vlog
they're doing I love this like weird
kind of fly on the wall and then it
turns into some kind of weird story of
chaos that usually involves everybody
getting each other yeah yeah I mean it's
the best payoff that way if you're just
kind of like oh it's just casual and
everything's fine and selling why I'm
like that's the coolest thing I think
YouTube has given us is like the ability
to completely create these surreal
realities we're like half the time
you're you and you're just talking about
life stuff and then at a moment's notice
you can just make it a short you can
just turn the style into something else
good stuff keep keep up the good work
keep keep destroying your you're really
nice man own it so you could subscribe
is a real reject hit that notification
bell to get updated every time a
reviewer of videos out make sure to
subscribe to raka raka my guest today
kyle i Lerman fancier channel comm yeah
go check out some of his videos give him
a hug follow him on instagram twitter at
the kyle Ehrman right and his correct
Kyle ermine and until next time I love
you all
oh and we got cool stuff on patreon to
come check out our patreon we got shirts
in our spread shirt shop
yeah until next time Cheers